♪ ♪
>> Brian: THE DOJ'S ARE GIVING
IT DOESN'T NEED A SPECIAL MASTER
TO REVIEW MATERIALS SEIZED ON
THE FBI RAID AT MAR-A-LAGO AS IT
ACCUSES THE TRUMP TEAM OF
REMOVING AND CONCEALING
DOCUMENTS, OR INDICATED SO MUCH.
IT COMES AS A TOUGH FBI AGENT
RESIGNS AMID ALLEGATIONS OF BIAS
RELATED TO THE HUNTER BIDEN
PROBE, AN ACCUSATION HE NOW
DENIES AND SAYS HE WASN'T EVEN
ON THE CASE.
HERE TO REACT, THE HOST OF
"UNFILTERED WITH DAN BONGINO."
YOUR REACTION TO THE REVELATIONS
COMING FORWARD ABOUT WHAT WAS OR
WASN'T AT MAR-A-LAGO?
>> LET ME SAY FIRST, YOU KNOW
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT WORKING HERE,
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT
OPINIONS, EVEN ON THE COUCH.
I DISAGREE STRONGLY WITH PEOPLE
AT THE NETWORK WHO WANT TO
DEFAULT TO TRUSTING THE FBI,
BECAUSE I ASK A QUESTION THAT
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THIS IS YOU,
OF COURSE, BUT WHY WOULD YOU
TRUST THE FBI WHEN IT COMES TO
TRUMP?
CAN YOU GIVE ME A REASON,
ANYONE?
>> Brian: ZERO.
>> WHERE HAVE THEY SHOWN ANY
DOCUMENTED HISTORY OF UNBIASED,
NONPARTISAN LAW-ENFORCEMENT-TYPE
ACTIVITY?
THE ANSWER IS IN NO TRUMP CASE
EVER.
SO YOUR DEFAULT DEFENSE OF THE
FBI IS OUTRAGEOUS.
LET ME JUST GIVE YOU -- LET'S GO
THROUGH THE LIST.
LET ME GIVE YOU ANOTHER
ARGUMENT.
FIRST OF ALL, WE'VE GOT TO TRUST
THE FBI?
WE DON'T HAVE TO TRUST THE FBI.
I DON'T.
YOU WANT TO TRUST THE FBI?
GOOD LUCK.
YOU HAVE NO RECORD TO BACK THAT
UP.
YOU SAY IT'S JUST A FEW BAD
APPLES?
IS THAT?
LETS GO THROUGH A LIST OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN EITHER ALLEGED
CORRUPTION OR DOCUMENT IN
CORRUPTION.
JIM COMEY, ANDY McCABE,
BILL PRIESTAP.
HAD TO WRITE THIS DOWN SO I
DIDN'T FORGET THEM ALL.
JIM BAKER, LISA PAGE,
PETER STRZOK, STEPHEN SEMI, JOE
BIANCO, KEVIN CLINESMITH, BRIAN
OTTEN, TIM TEBOW, AND THOSE ARE
JUST PEOPLE YOU KNOW ABOUT.
SOME ALLEGED, SOME DOCUMENTED,
GRANTED EVERYONE IS INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY, I BELIEVE
THAT, BUT IT'S A ROTTEN ORCHARD,
NOT A BAD APPLE.
WHEN YOU SAID THE DOJ SAYS THEY
DON'T NEED A SPECIAL MASTER TO
REVIEW THIS, JUST TRUST US, WE
WILL REVIEW IT OURSELVES WITH
THE FBI, YOU KNOW IT?
I'M GOING TO TAKE A HARD PASS ON
THAT BECAUSE WE TRUSTED YOU IN
THE PAST AND YOU TOLD US THAT IT
WAS A PP TAPE, RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, AND A DNC HACK, AND
YOU HAVE BACKED UP NONE OF THAT.
SO GIVE THEM A BIG ZERO ON THE
CREDIBILITY SCALE.
>> Brian: AND LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE LIVES THEY RUINED.
REMEMBER WHEN THEY PUT
PAPADAPOULOS INTO JAIL,
MANAFORT, AND HE'S GOING TO HAVE
A HEARING EVEN TODAY.
SO YOU HAVE ALL HIS CFO OF THE
COMPANY, AND THESE
INVESTIGATIONS HAVE BEEN
NONSTOP.
THEN YOU HAVE TEBOW TODAY,
WHISTLE-BLOWERS AND THE FBI BLEW
THE WHISTLE ON HIM, HE HAD BEEN
SET ASIDE, "I'M GOING TO
RETIRE," HE GETS WALKED OUT ON
FRIDAY, AND THAT WAS THE
BALTIMORE OFFICE, THE
INVESTIGATION AND SUPPRESSION OF
THE LAPTOP.
I'M PRETTY SURE WE CAN GIVE HIM
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS RAID IN
PARTICULAR.
IF I AM THE FBI AND I'M THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND I AM
SO CONFIDENT THE PRESIDENT WAS
SO EGREGIOUS WE HAD TO STORM THE
GATES AFTER WINNING FOR THREE
WEEKS AND THREE DAYS WITH THIS
WARRANT, IF I'M SO CONFIDENT, I
WELCOME THE SPECIAL MASTER.
GET ME OUT OF IT.
YOU CHECK IT OUT.
BUT THAT'S THE PICTURE --
>> I LOVE THE PICTURES THEY ARE
SHOWING, TOP-SECRET COVERS.
THEY ARE COVERS.
YOU ARE ASSUMING, BY THE WAY
THAT I GET IT, A LOT OF IT IS
BLACKED OUT, REJECTED.
I'M NOT STUPID.
BUT HERE'S THE POINT HERE, I
DEALT WITH A LOT OF CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL IN THE SECRET SERVICE,
LIKE MOTORCADE ROUTES.
I'VE GOT NEWS FOR YOU, AFTER THE
ROUTE IS RUN AND 100,000 PEOPLE
SAW THE MOTORCADE ROUTE, IT'S
NOT CLASSIFIED ANY MORE.
I'M NOT TELLING YOU THOSE
DOCUMENTS ARE CLASSIFIED,
BECAUSE I'M NOT A LEFTIST MEDIA
LOSER WHO JUMPS TO CONCLUSIONS.
I'M SIMPLY TELLING YOU JUMPING
TO THE CONCLUSION AND ASSUMING
THE FBI STORY THAT IT IS
CLASSIFIED AS EQUALLY DUMB.
NOT TO MENTION THERE IS
PRECEDENT HERE.
WE DEAL WITH LEGAL PRECEDENT.
AS A 2012 CASE, EVERYBODY CAN
BELIEVES IT OUT.
JUDGE AMY BERMAN JACKSON, AND
THE CLINTON CASE WHERE HE
ALLEGEDLY HAD CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS, WHERE JUDGE JACKSON
SAID THE PRESIDENT HAS THE SOLE
DISCRETION.
TO MANAGE HIS OWN RECORDS, AND
TO SAY WHAT'S PERSONAL AND
WHAT'S NOT.
THAT'S REALLY FUNNY HOW THAT IS
LEFT OUT OF ALL THE ANALYSIS,
AND EVERYBODY, EVEN SOME FRIENDS
OF MINE ON THE NETWORK, JUST
SAY, "HEY, IT'S CLASSIFIED."
AND YOU KNOW THAT HOW?
YOU ARE JUST ASSUMING BECAUSE
THE FBI TOLD YOU THAT.
SO YOU'RE JUST ASSUMING.
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW ANY OF
THAT.
BY THE WAY, YOU IGNORE THAT IT
IS SOLE DISCRETION.
ONE MORE THING ABOUT TEBOW, BY
THE WAY.
HE MAY BE TELLING THE TRUTH AND
HE MAY NOT, I'LL GIVE HIM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT BECAUSE I'M
INTERESTED IN FACTS.
BUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, IF HE'S
TELLING THE TRUTH, HE'S RISKING
HIS JOB BY SAYING WHAT TEBOW
DID.
BY LYING, HE COULD SAVE HIS JOB.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT A BALANCE OF
MOTIVES, YOU NEED TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND.
TEBOW NEEDS TO LIE TO KEEP HIS
JOB.
HE MAY BE TELLING THE TRUTH, HE
MAY NOT.
BUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER COULD
LOSE HIS JOB BY TELLING THE
TRUTH AND SAYING HERE'S WHAT
HAPPENED AT THE FBI.
SO LET'S BE CAREFUL BEFORE WE
JUMP --
>> Brian: IF I'M AN FBI AGENT,
I WOULD LOVE TO SAY, "LISTEN, I
HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM WITH WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE," BUT I DON'T GO
TO CHRISTOPHER WRAY.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON,
SENATOR CHUCK GRASSLEY,
JIM JORDAN.
THEY HAVE A CREDIBILITY ON THE
LINE.
EVIDENTLY HE WAS CORROBORATED.
THEY SAID HE ROSE TO PUBLIC
ATTENTION IS 1 OF 13 ASSISTANT
SPECIAL AGENTS INVESTIGATING
BIDEN'S LAPTOP.
HE WAS LIKE, THESE PEOPLE SAY IT
WAS DONE BY THE BALTIMORE
BUREAU.
OKAY.
THEY DID SOMETHING SEEMINGLY
PRETTY UNSAVORY TO SUPPRESS
INFORMATION RATHER THAN PICK UP
THE PHONE AND SAY, "HEY, HUNTER,
IS THIS YOUR EMAIL?
DEVON ARCHER, IS THIS YOUR
EMAIL?
CAN WE FIND OUT THE BUSINESSMAN
AT THE OTHER END OF THIS IN
CHINA, UKRAINE, RUSSIA, ROMANIA,
OR WHATEVER?"
NO IF IT WAS DONE.
SUPPRESSION WAS MADE.
A YEAR AND HALF LATER IT TURNS
OUT IT WAS TRUE, EVEN BILL BARR
BRINGS IT UP AND SAYS, "GUYS, IS
REALLY THAT BAD?
WE HAVE TO SUPPRESS A STORY IN
ORDER TO GET HIM ELECTED?"
AND HE DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM.
TO SEE THE BIG PICTURE, AND I
NEGLECT TO SEE THE FBI FIGHT IT
OUT IN FRONT OF US SO WE COULD
FIND OUT WHO'S RIGHT.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> I'M JUST ACTING DUMB LIKE
ASKING PEOPLE DOWN'S EQUITIES.
MARK ZUCKERBERG SAYS THEY
PRESSURED HIM ABOUT RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, DEEP STATER
SIGNED A LETTER TO MAKE IT GO
AWAY, AND THEY SAY THEY'RE
SUPPRESSING THE STORY, AND YOU
STILL HAVE PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
LIKE, "I'M REALLY NOT SURE I
BELIEVE IT."
THAT'S BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO
BELIEVE IT, THAT'S WHY.
YOU'VE GOT TO VIEW IT AS AN
INVESTIGATOR, NOT AS A PARTISAN
SOMETIMES.
AND THE TRUTH WILL COME TO
LIGHT.
>> Brian: AND THE GENIUS
RETREATED SOME SOCIAL MEDIA THAT
SHOWS EXACTLY WHAT HE STOOD,
SAME AS PETER STRZOK'S TEXT
MESSAGES,